Gaul is a whole divided into three parts
one of which is inhabited by the Belgae
another by the aquitanian a third by a
people called in their own tongue Celt a
in the latin galley all these are
different from one another in language
institutions and laws the gallery are
separated from the aqua tani by the
river Gowron from the Belgae by the man
and the sin of all these peoples the
belgae are the most courageous because
they are the farthest removed from the
culture and civilization of the province
unleased often visited by merchants
introducing the commodities that make
for effeminacy and also because they are
nearest to the germans dwelling beyond
to the rhine with whom they are
continually at war for this cause the
Helvetii also excel the rest of the
girls in valor either endeavoring to
keep them out of Gallic territory or
waging aggressive warfare in German
territory the separate part of the
country which as has been said is
occupied by the Gauls starts from the
river Rome and is bounded by the river
Garen the ocean and the territory of the
Belgae
moreover on the side of the sequani and
the helvetii
it touches on the river rhine and it's
general trend is northward the Belgae
beginning from the edge of the Gallic
territory reached to the lower part of
the River Rhine bearing towards the
north and east Aquitania starting from
the Garron reaches to the pyrenees and
to that part of the ocean which is by
spain its bearing is between west and
north
since i have arrived at this point it
would seem to be not inappropriate to
set forth the customs of goal and of
germany and the difference between these
nations in gaul not only in every state
in every canton and district but almost
in every several household there are
parties and the leaders of the parties
are men who in the judgments of their
fellows are deemed to have the highest
authority meander whose decision and
judgment this
Preem issue of all cases and councils
may be referred and this seems to have
been an ordinance from ancient days to
the end that no man of the people should
lack assistance against a more powerful
neighbor rich man refuses to allow his
own folk to be oppressed and defrauded
since otherwise he has no authority
among them the same principle holds in
regard to Gaul as a whole
taken together for the whole body of
states is divided into two parties among
God's they most worship mercury
there are numerous images of him they
declare him the inventor of all arts the
guide for every road and journey and
they deem him to have the greatest
influence for all money-making and
traffic after him they set Apollo Mars
Jupiter and Minerva of these deities
they have almost the same idea as all
other nations Apollo drives away the
seizes Minerva supplies the first
principles of arts and crafts Jupiter
holds the Empire of heaven Mars controls
wars to Mars when they have determined
on the decisive battle they dedicate as
a rule whatever spoiled that they take
after a victory they sacrifice such
living things as they have taken and all
the other effects they gather into one
place in many states heaps of such
objects are to be seen piled up in
hallowed spots and it has and often
happened that a man in defiance of
religious scruple has dared to conceal
such spoils in his house or to remove
them from their place and the most
grievous punishment with torture is
ordained for such an offence the Gauls
affirm that they are all descended from
a common father dis and say that this is
the tradition of the Druids for that
reason they determine all periods of
time by the number not of days but of
nights pending their observance of
birthdays and the beginning of months in
years day follows night and the other
ordinances of life the main difference
between them and the rest of mankind
is that they do not allow their own sons
to approach them openly until they have
grown to an age where they can bear the
burden of military service and they
counted a disgrace for son who was still
in his boy to take his place publicly in
the presence of his father the men after
making a Jew reckoning take from their
own goods a sum of money equal to the
dowry that they've received from their
wives and place it with the dowry of
each some account is kept between them
and the profits saved whichever of the
two survives receives the portion of
both together with the profits of past
years men have the power of life and
death over their wives as over their
children and when the father of the
house who is a distinguished birth has
died his relatives assemble and if there
be anything suspicious about his death
they make Inquisition of his wives as
they would have slaves and if discovery
is made they put them to death with fire
and all manner of excruciating tortures
their funerals considering the
civilization of Gaul are magnificent and
expensive
they cast into the fire everything even
living creatures which they believed to
have been dear to departed during life
and but a short time before the present
age only a generation since slaves and
dependents known to have been beloved by
their Lords used to be burnt with them
at the conclusions the funeral
formalities
those states which are supposed to
conduct their public administration to
greater advantage have it prescribed by
law that anyone who has learned anything
a public concern from his neighbors by
rumor or report must bring the
information to a magistrate and not
impart it to anyone else for it is
recognized that often times hasty and
inexperienced man are terrified by false
rumors and so I driven to crime or to
decide supreme issues magistrates
conceal what they choose and make known
what they think proper for the public
speech on state questions except by
means of an assembly is not allowed
among the Helvetii the noblest man by
far the most wealthy was orgetorix in
the consulship of marcus masala and
Marcus P so his desire for the kingship
led him to form a conspiracy of the
nobility and he persuaded the community
to march out of their territory in full
force
urging that as they excelled all in
Valley it was easy enough to secure the
sovereignty of all Gaul and this he
persuaded them the more easily because
the Helvetii are closely confined by the
nature of their territory on one side
there is the River Rhine exceeding broad
and deep which separates the hell vision
territory from the Germans and on
another the Jura range exceeding high
lying between sequani and the helvetii
on the third the lake of Geneva and the
river Rhone which separates the Roman
province from the helvetii
in such circumstances their range of
movement was less extensive and on this
account they were greatly distressed for
they were men that longed for war no
they could not but consider that the
territory that they occupied to an
extent of 240 miles long and 180 broad
was all too narrow for their population
and for their renown of courage in a war
swayed by these considerations and
stirred by the influence of Olga Toric's
they determined to collect what they
needed for taking the field to buy up as
large a number as they could of the
draft cattle and carts to sow as much
corn as possible so as to have a
sufficient supply thereof on the March
and to establish peace and Amity with
the nearest communities for the
accomplishment of these objects they
considered that two years were
sufficient and pledged themselves by an
ordinance to take the field in the third
year when Caesar was informed that they
were endeavoring to march through the
Roman province he made speed to leave
Rome and hastening to further Gaul by
his rapid stages as possible arrived
near Geneva from the whole province he
requisitioned the largest possible
number of troops there was in further
Gaul no more than a single Legion and
ordered the bridge at Geneva to be
broken down when the helvetii learned of
his coming they sent his deputies to him
the noblest man of their state in Emmaus
and Vera Chloe sheis held the chief
palace in the deputation with
instructions to say that their purpose
was to march through the province
without any mischeif because they had no
other route and they asked that they
might have to leave so to do of his good
will
remembering that the Consul douchiest
cassis had been slain and his army
routed and sent under the yoke by the
Helvetii Caesar considered that no
concession should be made nor did he
believe that men of unfriendly
disposition if granted the opportunity
of marching through the province would
refrain from outrage and mischief
[Music]
you